on your screen is a University of
Illinois at Chicago philosophy professor
his name is Samuel fly shocker
and he's also president of the
international Adam Smith Society
professor fly shocker who was Adam Smith
well I had him actually that's not such
an easy question to answer but he was a
moral philosopher in Scotland and
eighteen in the 18th century who wrote a
book on moral philosophy first and used
to give a set of lectures that took you
from moral philosophy through law to
economics and eventually wrote a very
long book on economics often considered
the founding text in the field called
the inquiry into the nature and causes
of the wealth of nations and he's been
extremely influential ever since
although as a philosopher I wish people
would look at him more as a philosopher
than just as an economist and we will
get to that but professor Russell
Roberts of George Mason University what
has been the impact of the wealth of
nations the wealth of nations besides
teaching people a lot of economics along
the centuries since it was published in
1776 really set a whole tone for social
science the combination of empirical
work observation logic philosophy all
melted together it's really an
extraordinary work that has had an
enormous impact on scholars and the real
world not just scholars pergo people
professor Fleisch Acker when we talk
about moral philosophy what do we mean
by that well what Smith meant by it was
something close to what we call social
science in part that is to say
everything that we today call psychology
sociology economics political science
all that would be part of moral
philosophy as opposed to natural
philosophy natural philosophy is what
Newton did moral philosophy covers what
we call the social sciences but it also
meant for him as it does for us the
study of what's right and wrong good and
bad what human beings are aiming for
what they aspire to and those things are
part of his vision of social science I
would say how groundbreaking was his
work it was enormous
the influential as Russell said almost
from the moment it was written certainly
by say the 1790s it was being read all
over the prime minister of england as of
the 1780s William Pitt was had read it
already in college the founders of the
United States especially Thomas
Jefferson and James Madison were very
much influenced by it and we're looking
to it for guidance as they shaped this
country and then by the time of the
French Revolution that was extremely
important in France and Germany so in a
lot of ways it was the go-to book if you
wanted to figure out what governments
should do about the economy but also
what governments to do in general
professor Russell Roberts do you use
Adam Smith's theories in teaching
economics at George Mason well I I do
actually his insights into the division
of labor and specialization and trade I
think are incredibly timely we are the
only University that I know of at George
Mason has a field in smithy and
political economy I teach going I hope
to teach class in that with my
colleagues Don Boudreau and Daniel Klein
so we take Smith quite seriously as a
role model for how social science should
be conducted what about You professor
fly shocker do you use Adam Smith in
your classes well I do but I should say
that as well as being a moral and
political philosopher I'm a historian of
moral and political philosophy so I'm
expected to teach some of the classics
of the field especially of the field in
the 18th century so I do regularly teach
a course on Scottish moral philosophy in
the 18th century that includes figures
like David Hume as well as Adam Smith
and I like to suggest to students that
Smith provides a quite remarkable model
of how philosophy and social science can
be brought together and sometimes look
at his moral philosophy in connection
with The Wealth of Nations and see how
they interact well good evening and
welcome to this special edition of book
TV on c-span 2 in primetime we will be
live for the next hour looking at Adam
Smith's The Wealth of Nations and we
want to take your calls emails in tweet
so if you'd like to call in to our two
guests will tell you a little bit more
about them in a second but if you'd like
to call in with our two guests and talk
about Adam Smith and the Wealth of
Nations here's the numbers for you to
call 202 is the area code 737 triple
zero one if you live in the East and
central time zones 202 seven thirty
seven triples zero two for those of you
in the mountain and Pacific time zones
and you can always send us a email at
book TV at c-span org or you can send us
a tweet twitter.com slash book TV is our
twitter address now our two guests are
Samuel Fleisch Acker and he is in
Chicago right now and he is a professor
at the University of Illinois in Chicago
and he is also president of the
international Adam Smith Society
professor fly shaker what is that
society that was a society founded about
that is a society founded about 15 years
ago to encourage more scholarly interest
in Smith one of our models was the Hume
society which did help ratchet up
interest especially among philosophers
in David Hume Smith is of interest to
not just philosophers or a Kannamma sin
as to intellectual historians to
literary theorists often these days and
we encourage the study of Smith from all
and no political perspective that's to
say we try to stay away from the
political uses of Smith for ideological
purposes and simply in college encourage
scholarly work on what he had to say in
all these various areas and we have
conferences basically at least once a
year and and also try to encourage
scholarly work in various other forums
now you've mentioned David Hume twice
who was he David Hume is one of the most
important moral law and most important
philosophers most people would say of
the modern period that is since about
1600 he was a radical empiricist that is
someone who tried to develop a theory of
knowledge and of morals entirely on the
basis of experience that led him in
certain ways to be something of a
skeptic raising doubts about the
existence of causality even of our
selves and serious doubts about religion
he was also Adam Smith's best friend and
he preceded Adam Smith in writing
interesting essays on economics and many
of his insights in fact Smith
incorporates and then systematizes in
the inquiry into the wealth of nations
and our other guest is Russell Roberts
who is an economics professor at George
Mason University here in the Washington
DC area and a research fellow at the
Hoover Institution he has a weekly
podcast called econ talk what is that
it's an hour-long interview with
economists authors the guy who sold me
my car and expert on ants anything I
think that's interesting that's about
the world around us and is related to
economics including a six-part series I
did with Dan Klein on the Theory of
Moral Sentiments Adam Smith's first book
a little bit intense but for those who
are deeply interested a more scholarly
diversion than we usually do any contact
would you consider yourself a fan of
Adam Smith's theories big-time why it's
startling how something written so long
ago with such charm is still educational
and valuable my thesis advisor at the
University of Chicago Gary Becker won a
Nobel Prize when asked who are the
economists who most influenced him he
said Adam Smith and Alfred Marshall I
thought we just kind of exaggerated we
should go back and read Smith there's so
many insights there and again he's such
a role model for how to use observation
fact evidence and introspection to think
about the world around us well before we
go to calls there's one phrase that Adam
Smith is very well known for the
invisible hand now we're going to take
that from The Wealth of Nations and
we're going to read the quote to you
where he uses the the phrase invisible
hand with a little bit of text before it
and afterwards so it gets a little long
here but we thought you'd want to see it
in perspective and this is from Adam
Smith's The Wealth of Nations book for
chapter 2 by preferring the support of
domestic to that of foreign industry he
intends only his own security and by
directing that industry in such a manner
as its produce may be of the greatest
value he intends only his own gay
and he is in this as in many other cases
led by an invisible hand to promote an
end which was no part of his intention
nor is it always the worse for society
that it was no part of it by pursuing
his own interest he frequently promotes
that of society more effectually than
when he really intends to promote it I
have never known much good done by those
who effected to trade for the public
good what does that mean well it means
an immense amount of different things to
different people what it means to my
understanding of Smith and to the world
around us is he was drawing on a
tradition that was a little preceding -
he's considered the first economist but
Adam Ferguson who came before him was
also a Scot talked about things that
were the result of human action but not
human design and he take that lineage
Ferguson Adam Smith - Hayek the great
20th century economist they're all
interested in outcomes that are
beneficial sometimes harmful but usually
beneficial that no one intended we often
think of the law of unintended
consequences being negative and it often
is what Smith and Hayek and Ferguson
we're talking about was human action
that creates an emergent order not
designed from the top down but from the
bottom up by individual making decisions
based on the knowledge that they have
access access to that no one else does
understanding that in my view of
economics is the single deepest thing
economists understand that is an obvious
or just common sense it's profoundly
deep it's nuanced it's subtle
it gets caricatured a lot as if
everything's going to turn out ok that's
not what Smith understood it to mean and
Smith also had a divine aspect to it the
invisible hand has the end of the divine
he uses the same metaphor in the Theory
of Moral Sentiments and he argues that
people through their internal conscience
and their worries about what other
people think of them are led to do
things that make the the entire society
better off it's a very deep and subtle
idea it's a it's a beautiful idea
Samuel Fleischer said jump in for a sec
I agree with most of what Russell said
the the
the exact meaning of the idea of the
invisible hand is very contentious among
Scott Smith scholars these days some say
that it refers to the divine Smith uses
it exactly three times in all his work
and in one case it does clearly refer to
the divine here in The Wealth of Nations
many people and I'd be among them would
say there is no reference to the divine
it's just a metaphor that he's found
useful elsewhere whether there's any
kind of religious background to his
economic theory as I said is a very
controversial but I think Russell's main
point is the one to focus on here
whether there is or not Smith gives us a
purely naturalistic secular account of
how orders can arise without anybody
intending them and for the most part how
individual action can for the most part
produce something quite good for society
as a whole without people intending it
now one thing that Smith Smith has in
mind and this is the one thing that I'd
want to add to what Russell said is that
he he's opposed to the idea that went
ought to think that the society would be
better in many cases if there were a
visible hand that is on the one hand he
thinks the government's don't
necessarily do a better job in fact
usually do a worse job in running
economies and on the other hand he
dislikes as he says in the last
sentences you quoted he just likes it
when merchants claim to be doing
something for the good of society
interestingly there's a letter Smith
wrote about the same time about a year
earlier in which he refers to Josiah
Wedgwood the famous founder of the
pottery firm claiming that he wanted a
certain law which was actually going to
benefit his firm for the good of England
and Smith says in the letter essentially
he'd much rather of Wedgwood admitted
that he's doing it for himself
basically Smith doesn't trust merchants
when they claim that they're doing
something for the good of the public he
thinks it's better if they simply act
for their private interests and if
everyone does that on the whole though
again as Russell said and this is very
important he doesn't think this is true
in every case on the whole when
people pursue their self-interest in a
well-organized society it will conduce
the public good yeah it's I like that
that point about Smith's worries about
people claiming to be serving the public
good it brings to mind the CEO of
Goldman Sachs Lloyd Blankfein who
recently was quoted as saying he does
God's work as an investment banker
making sure capital flows to its highest
valued use that's a lovely idea
unfortunately in the current system
which is more crony capitalism the real
capitalism he serves goldman sachs and
masquerades to be serving the public
interest and I I think I suspect Smith
wouldn't even think it's so lovely I
think he'd consider it quite typically
but yes but Smith understood that a
temptation on the part of the merchant
or the business person to cloak his
self-interest in the public interest in
it how dangerous it was
Samuel Fleischer give us a brief bio of
Adam Smith where was he raised where did
he go to school etc okay I hope your
viewers don't fall asleep in this he has
one of those boring lives of any
important human being he his father died
before he was born
he lived in it he was born in a small
town in Scotland called Kirkcaldy he
supposedly was kidnapped by gypsies when
he was about seven years old and then
released a few years if you have a few
days a weeks later that's the most
interesting thing in his lifetime after
that he went to university in Glasgow
got a special scholarship to go on to
Oxford came back and taught in Oxford he
was actually a professor which isn't
that common for some of the major
intellectuals of the time Hume was never
a professor Fergusson was largely not a
professor and he took over the course of
his own major teacher Francis Hutcheson
after that he was hired by a rich
nobleman to tutor his kids and supported
for the rest of his life on that money
even though he only tutored the kids for
a couple of years and then he retired to
sit at home and write The Wealth of
Nations and funnily enough after writing
The Wealth of Nations in which he argues
against duties of any kind
he became a commissioner of customs for
about a decade and then died quietly at
home in Scotland very rich from various
sources although apparently he gave most
of his money away quietly without
telling anyone so that he died without
much wealth to his name and that's about
it
Russell Roberts did he ever visit the
United States I don't think so though
Sam Sam can verify that no no he visited
very few places he went to Paris and he
met a lot of major intellectuals in
France he met Voltaire which meant a lot
to him but aside from that one trip to
the continent I don't think he traveled
very much outside of the British Isles
well let's get to our viewers calls 202
737 triple zero one if you live in the
East and central time zones 202 737
triple zero two for the Pacific and
mountain time zones and book TV at
suspend org for an email and book TV at
book TV is our twitter address Rochester
New York Andrew you're on with Samuel
fly shocker and Russel Roberts thank you
thank you gentlemen for coming on
tonight my question is what about that
that mr. Smith have anything to say
about a war tax I heard that there was a
war tax and that General Washington had
a war tax I was wondering if he's if he
talked about what his views were on debt
and things like that
professor fly shocker well there is a
long Latin complicated and very
technical last section of the wealth of
nations devoted to taxes very much
admired by politicians of the time in
fact some of them at first just picked
up the book and ransacked the back to
see what which taxes might be most
useful and in there he talks about
funding of Wars quite explicitly he
talks about what was called the sinking
fund which was a kind of debt system by
which Britain financed its Wars he
complains about that way of financing
wars for technical reasons that I'm
going to leave it to Russell to explain
if he wishes and says that he would
prefer if wars were funded by a tax paid
in every year that therefore
one reason he says that would be
advantageous is that would make the Wars
shorter people would be irritated by
paying the tax and that would make them
call for the war to come to an end I'm I
don't get to Russell to say anything
else on this well my only comment on on
Smith and taxes which is so
extraordinary for his time is he deeply
understood who really paid the tax as
opposed to who the tax was supposed to
be paid by and he also understood the
incentives that politicians and tax
payers dealt with and you know Sam's
example of the pain of war being paid
for in the contemporary times is a
tremendous example of what Smith was
always aware of which was how incentives
worked in in affecting both politics and
private life gentlemen we have a tweet
here from Joe Orlando book man Joe he
goes by and he writes who cares why
should we care about Adam Smith well as
I said I teach a class in microeconomics
almost every year I've taught for about
30 years and I've often assumed as most
economists do that David Ricardo's
insights into trade are the right ones
that diversity is a powerful generator
trade I've come to understand recently
that actually Smith had perhaps the more
important idea which is the role that
economies of scale and division of
labour have and specialization even were
all the same he has a lot to teach us
still a it's not always easy reading the
first three or four chapters of The
Wealth of Nations can be read by anyone
today with profit he has deep
understandings that are still relevant
the Theory of Moral Sentiments a first
seven chapters okay eager even bored
willing to grant generous than you yeah
it's okay but the Theory of Moral
Sentiments his first book starts out
very slowly very difficult to read but
if you get into it it's extremely modern
it's all about our self esteem or
self-worth the tension between our
self-interest and doing the right thing
it's a tremendously powerful book and
still very much worth reading and I
finally we died again on trade submits
remarks on trade policy his subtle and
ironic understanding of self-interest of
merchants acting often by claiming to be
in the public interest the role of
politicians still very timely still
worth reading I
I would add two quick thoughts to that
one is Smith is sighted of course very
widely by people for political purposes
to this day he cited as a a moral source
as well as economic source of the
importance of a free trading economy of
what's called libertarianism of
classical liberalism and then he is also
cited by people more on the left there's
a quite a debate between let's say left
and right Smith Ian's and in many ways
he has been the origin of ideas that are
still very much alive and kicking in the
party in the political scene and if one
wants to trace how we've come to these
ideas our own heritage our own history
how these ideas have come to be kicking
around on the political landscape one
really needs to read Smith the other
thing that I'd say is that as a founder
of social science and this goes back to
something that Russell said in the
beginning of the program he sets a model
for how social science might be done and
he sets a model in which scientific
observation is integrated with moral
thought in a way that isn't always true
and laid among later social scientists
and in that sense I think he's still
very inspiring with reading with looking
to as a model Harrisburg Pennsylvania
Bob please go ahead with your question
about Adam Smith's The Wealth of Nations
yeah hi good evening gentlemen
I'd like to know if wow I like either
the professors to comment on any
relationships between Adam Smith and
Marxism and where would someone from the
20th century such as ayan Rand where
would she fit in regarding their two
philosophies Thanks thank you let's
start in Chicago with Samuel fly shocker
well many people who study marks on our
Marxist point out that Marx for all that
he identified Smith in large part with a
system that he Marx thought should be
overthrown or was due to the past he
couldn't get away from admiring Smith he
he quotes Smith is a very honest thinker
and in fact incorporates some of the
more remarkable things Smith says of
the suffering and oppression of poor
workers as things that he himself could
still hold and in fact there is a move
now I should say even though I
sympathize with the sort more left-wing
uses of Smith I'm not a Marxist I'm not
so interested in this myself but there
is a move among many people who were
very interested in Marx and have a sort
of Marxist orientation towards political
economy to recover Smith all over the
Academy especially that many people
interested Matsu recovering Smith I
personally don't see any interesting
relationship between Smith and Enron I
think there may be others who do her
emphasis on self interest only I think
it's quite alien to Smith I think he's a
very different view of how economies
work and how societies work yeah I want
to emphasize that as well I think poor
Adam Smith gets caricatured as the
defender of greed right he's not a
defender of greed he was someone who
understood the power of self-interest
that most of us put ourselves first
that's human nature he took it as it was
and he urged us in his first book the
theory world sentiments to overcome that
and he talked about how sometimes we do
and sometimes we don't the other part
that's I think Randian about Smith
that's fascinating is Smith in the
Theory of Moral Sentiments talks about
the importance of happiness and he talks
about how it appears to him that the
world was created for the happiness of
humanity and that's really an
extraordinary idea I think a lot of
people learn from ein Rand that it's ok
to follow your own happiness but Smith
was certainly not a a hedonist or a
libertine he was a huge put a huge
emphasis on the importance of moral
values and conscience and doing the
right thing that I think is often absent
from Iran so the first edition of The
Wealth of Nations was finished in 1776
did it play any role in the u.s.
revolution well as as as Sam pointed
earlier the founders read Smith he did
revise it and Sam will know the dates he
revised that I think it's 1782 yeah
quite quite a bit Theory of Moral
Sentiments I think came out in the 1750s
and I don't know how influential it was
Jefferson had read the Theory of Moral
Sentiments by 1771 the the President of
Princeton at the time of the Revolution
and before was a man named John
Witherspoon who was a Scot and he
educated many of the founders and they
read what he as a Scot thought was worth
readings with the spoon is also a sign
of the Declaration of Independence and
so forth and he thought Smith's Theory
of Moral Sentiments was very worth
reading
I wouldn't say however that The Wealth
of Nations played a role in the
revolution what it did play a role in
very clearly so is the debates over the
Constitution people were reading it many
of the most important founders were
reading it by the mid 1780s they were
looking at Smith's discussion of
national banks they were looking at his
discussions of militias and standing
armies many aspects of the wealth of
nations were very important to the
founders and in fact Smith gets cited in
debates over the Constitution in 1787
and 1788 our next call for our guest
comes from John in Dallas Texas please
go ahead yes I study the wealth of
nations and the terrible Moral
Sentiments together when I was in
college back in the 60s and I my
professor insisted that you can't
understand one without the other and I I
wondered it I read it broke books again
in the last two years and I was amazed
at how powerful it is particularly three
Moral Sentiments he does a powerful job
of explaining and reviewing all
philosophy Plato and Aristotle and later
philosophers and he exercised the
importance of that and human behavior
and then he goes on in the breath of
Nations he talks a lot about the
importance of savings and accumulation
of capital and how money comes to be and
he talks about the colonies and he talks
about the Indies and early in the
colonization and the point of all this
when you read it it
god it's still relevant today and I
wonder to what extent our students and
our legislators who studied this enough
they really understand because it's
relevant it seems to me to what is going
on today and I guess my basic question
is how do you think this still relates
to the events were seeing today
particularly with what we've done to our
money and what's going on in the
feelings that just [ __ ] your thinking on
it
thank you John hey John why did you pick
it back up and read it
what was your curiosity well I've always
I was an investment banker that's my
life and and I I've been around
investment banking but for most of my
life and I saw it being corrupted and I
wanted to pick it up again and I'm
naturally interested in philosophy and
all right we started rereading Aristotle
and then amazing I pick up the fairy
Moral Sentiments again it just is he's
so fun Smith is so clear in his
explanation and comparative he compares
the philosophies and the consequences
well one thing we haven't talked about
in the Theory of Moral Sentiments which
i think again it's so important to avoid
the caricature of Smith submit very
explicitly says that accumulation of
wealth doesn't make you happy and he
warns against it and he also talks in a
very modern way about gadgets and how
rich men will filled their pockets with
gadgets now they didn't have
BlackBerry's and iPhones then they had
toothpick holders and other things that
he mocks as a source of happiness and
prestige and says they're not real so
that the book is full of important moral
instruction that I think as you point
out they have to be read together and I
think what's myth saw is so important is
they're all a culture the role of
conscience the role of trust in making a
market system work although his market
system was very primitive compared to
compared to ours
so I the other thing I want to mention
we've talked about how he's he's a role
model for social science a lot of deep
insights into the real side of our lives
in an economy that are easily forgotten
fallacies that people subscribe to that
Smith understood centuries ago were
wrong his whole attack on mercantilism
his whole attack on the idea that
exports create wealth and imports are
bad
he understood in 1776 that that was a
flawed and fallacious idea he understood
that money the pieces of paper and the
gold and silver or in our real wealth
our real wealth came from what we
produce and he understood in the Theory
of Moral Sentiments that what we produce
is what gives us happiness and how we
produce it how we spend our time not to
be spending all our time at the office I
mean he's a profoundly inspiring thinker
in both his insights and his moral
instruction professor fly Shakur I I
think it's wonderful that the caller
studied both the Theory of Moral
Sentiments and the wealth nations
together in college that doesn't often
happen today and I wish it would happen
more often I agree with pretty much
everything that Russ just said I just
add Smith sets in the Theory of Moral
Sentiments that what most makes us happy
is conversation with friends its
sociability its having friends and
hanging out with them basically he
doesn't use that phrase of course but he
does talk a lot about conversation that
is the greatest source of happiness and
that's one of the reasons why morality
is essential to happiness because unless
you have a level a certain level of
decency you won't have any friends and
in that understanding it's very clear
this is something so interesting such an
interesting irony about this founder of
economics that material goods are really
not central to happiness anyone who
seeks material goods at the costs of
friendship and morality is making a huge
mistake for Smith and in this I think he
provides something that I think we can
usefully look back to here's a man who
praises the free market who is not
opposed to the accumulation of material
goods the main reason he wants countries
to be wealthy and he says is quite
explicitly is that he wants poor people
to be able to have enough to eat and
have clothing on their back and have
lodging the most important goods he
often calls him this he often says is
our food clothing and lodging in his
lectures that just abbreviated as FCL by
his student notes often and so material
goods are important he doesn't downplay
them he sees the role for them he
he sees the role for them especially in
helping people rise out of poverty but
they're not the goal they're not the
ultimate goal and when you read the two
books together you really can see that
clearly
yes myth says that man wants to be loved
and to be lovely meaning we care deeply
about how others perceive us and we want
to earn that respect honestly by being
lovely by doing the things that engender
love and I think what's and points out
which is extremely important is often
people even economists forget what the
purpose of economics is it's not about
accumulating material well-being wealth
is very important as Smith understood to
help people survive to live long
extremely important but it's only a part
of the story and economics people think
is about the stock market about interest
rates it is about those things but as a
student told me once for she had learned
from her teacher economics is the study
of how to get the most out of life
it's about our choices it's about the
fact that we don't have an infinite
amount of time an infinite amount of
money we have to use our time which is
so precious so wisely in the sociability
of friends and not merely accumulating
material good so in that sense I think
economics needs to come back to Smith
and not be as focused on the material
and I think it's useful that people
understand that that's an important role
in economics here's a quote from the
wealth of nations book 3 chapter 3 part
3 no large country it must be observed
ever did or could subsist without some
sort of manufacturers being carried on
in it and when it is said of any such
country that it has no manufacturers it
must always be understood of the finer
and more improved or of such as our fit
for distance sale well that's a little
bit misleading I think it might tend to
encourage you to think that making stuff
is the road to prosperity Smith
certainly didn't say that what he meant
what he believed was that our skills
should be used as widely and
successfully and productively as
possible and the way we do that is
through our three are free choices of
buying and selling and specialization
and in choosing what jobs to do etc what
I think these are for each in that
passage maybe Sam knows as well better
than I do I think he's referring to that
passage as he was comparing a semi
modern society of our standards where
there's some manufacturing to a more
primitive hunter-gatherer or even
agricultural society it was talking
about this natural transition he saw
from a hunter-gatherer to a role where
artifice where the making of stuff
became a way for people to use the
division of labour and it's famous
example the opening of the book is the
pin Factory or an individual by
cooperating with other people and
specializing and not trying to make the
pins all by oneself could produce an
enormous Li larger number of pins per
person it's really a deep understanding
of productivity and how productivity is
enhanced by exchange another way to
think about if I if I could just break
in for a second the quote from the book
three is actually that I agree it's
misleading in fact radically so in a way
it's actually part of his polemic
against the mercantilist theories that
manufacturing is better than agriculture
and what in Smith wants to one of the
main points of the Wealth of Nations as
a whole is to say manufacturing isn't
better than agriculture and agriculture
isn't better than manufacturing a
country should do whatever but whatever
it's best suited for or rather the
individuals in the car in the country if
you leave them alone to find their own
employment and this fits with what
Russell was just saying will naturally
seek the kind of work that is best
remunerated which means basically the
kind of work that's most needed by the
society so the government doesn't need
to promote manufacturing at the car at
the cost of Commerce sorry manufacturing
at the cost of agriculture or
agriculture the cost of manufacturing
and that may sound like a technical
point but in in the context of the day
where there were many people who thought
that the job of the government was to
promote the kind of industry that makes
countries richest and some people
thought that was manufacturing some
people thought it was agriculture Smith
says no leave the leave industry alone
let people find their own work and that
will be the best way to promote well
that idea which was popular in Smith's
time unfortunately is still very much
alive today where people think we have
to pick and choose the right activities
Ross Perot
said it's better to make computer chips
than potato chips that's true if you're
good at computer chips if you're not
you're going to just get even poor doing
something you're not good at Adam
Smith's importance when you compare him
to people like John Maynard Keynes FA
Hayek Milton Friedman well they stand
those shoulders of that giant they're
all influenced by smith Hayek and
Friedman I think more than Keynes but
I'm sure Keynes would would would see
himself as in the same tradition go
ahead professor how much I I mean one
difference between Smith and the others
is that none of the others that you
mentioned saw themselves as a moral
philosopher as well as an economist they
sometimes had very interesting things to
say about morality and about moral
philosophy in certain ways but Smith's
views I think integrate the study of
human nature from a philosophical point
of view with the study of human nature
in a more empirical way more than the
others do yeah let me just say a word
about that if I might
which also pertains to this question
about of how you read the Wealth of
Nations and the Theory of Moral
Sentiments together there's one thing
that we haven't mentioned that I think
we might want to add here and that is in
the Theory of Moral Sentiments Smith
makes clear that in order to understand
other human beings properly to
sympathize with them as he says we need
to imagine ourselves into their
situations and we need to do that in
great detail otherwise we won't really
appreciate what they're experiencing and
he uses that idea throughout the wealth
of nations and in particular he imagines
himself in the position of poor laborers
a great deal which a considerable number
of later economists didn't bother to do
that I think is the one that's part of
what I mean when I when I refer to Smith
is having this model of how you
integrate philosophical thinking about
human nature with empirical study and I
don't think that that's so true for some
of these later figures although of
course they're very important to in
their own ways yeah well the irony of
course is that Adam Smith coming earlier
and living in a poorer time than Milton
Freedman or Hayek or Keynes
he was less specialized and one of the
great aspects of economic growth is its
role and specialization and so of course
those guys were narrower they weren't as
although they're pretty pretty diverse
for economists all three of them J and
hurlburt field florida thank you for
holding you're on with Samuel Fleisch
Acker and Russel Roberts and Adam Smith
please go ahead
hi thank you thanks for taking the call
that is a fascinating subject I am
interested in the wealth of nations as
an exercise in social science and I've
taken a sort of a casual interest in
Adam Smith for years yet I've not read
the book so my question is who explains
Smith better than Smith is there you
know a one-volume clear and accurate
analysis or interpretation of what he
was communicating and if so what is that
title all right we'll start with You
professor fly shakka well I hate to set
you on that road because it is really
worthwhile reading Smith Russell said
before just the first three or four
chapters of The Wealth of Nations I said
verse seven you could try reading that
and maybe just as say the first couple
chapters apart - apart sorry for of The
Wealth of Nations which include the
famous invisible hand chapter and maybe
the beginning book five that alone would
be very useful I found I was introduced
to Smith first in high school by Robert
Hale Bronner's a little book on the
great economist and I found that a
fairly good clear summary of what Smith
has to say I think it's probably out of
date by now and some people will
probably take it to be biased there's a
man named D D Raphael ra ph AEL who has
at least one book I think two books
entitled Adam Smith which will give you
a pretty good summary very clearly put
and it's very short so I guess that's
what I'd recommend and I would mention
that at the library of economics of
Liberty which is econ ly bco and Li B
org you can find the entire wealth of
nations the entire Theory of Moral
Sentiments online available at no charge
searchable and it's a lovely and very
inexpensive way to get access to the to
the man and his ideas it's also
you'll find an essay thereby I think
it's Samuel flash agar on a deep inside
of Smith in treating people in a very
egalitarian way Smith it's a great essay
by Sam he points out that Smith unlike
most of his colleagues of the day
actually thought that poor people could
knew what was best for them for them
that he was an anti paternalist he
recognized that every human being had
knowledge that other people didn't have
and as a result were the best judge of
what was best for their own interest and
it's a very radical idea surprisingly
and it changed the world who promotes
Adam Smith more these days Republicans
or Democrats professor fly shocker
oh that's changed quite a bit over the
past 20 years I confess my interest in
Smith began just about exactly at the
moment of the fall of the Berlin Wall it
began shortly before I should say but I
think that they were great a number of
people in the mostly raw the left-wing
Academy who thought well ok Marx is dead
what should we read now and quite a few
found Smith and in fact this has also
happened in the political world Gordon
Brown the Prime Minister of Britain even
when he was Chancellor of the Czech
Exchequer has been a very proud and
enthusiastic reader of Smith I've been
told I will add that Barack Obama is
also read of Smith coming out of the
University of Chicago I wouldn't be
surprised so I think at this point
you'll find people on both sides of the
aisle quite enthusiastically quoting
Smith though sometimes for different
purposes which actually takes us back
right to the Smith's own time when
people on both sides of many issues
including some of the same issues we
talked about today cited Smith well I
think I agree with what Sam said but I
think Republicans have laid claim to
Smith unfortunately because they use
rhetoric that they think is Smith the
end about markets and competition they'd
often don't live up to it which i think
is a great tragedy I'd like to see
politicians actually internalize those
lessons rather than just use rhetoric
for covering up self-interest bill and
Fort Lauderdale good evening
good evening I thank you for taking my
question I
was interested in finding out from the
professor's essentially how John Maynard
Keynes might have been influenced in
specific areas I know that today
consumerism is the result of dr. King's
I believe and I was wondering if they
had any comment on that
professor Roberts well Keynesian and
Keynes himself were worried about people
saving too much
and not spending I do think that's a
mistake although a lot of people would
disagree with me a lot of people think
that consumerism as you described it is
the foundation of an economy that
certainly is not a Smith Ian idea
I think the part that is Smith Ian is
perhaps Keynes has interest in animal
spirits and what Keynes meant by animal
spirits he meant a few things but one of
the things he meant was the emotional
and psychological aspect of
entrepreneurs their confidence or their
worries and fears and Smith had a lot to
say about that Smith was very interested
in how people are often overconfident
about their prospects for success or
cautious or fearful about the future and
perhaps Keynes was influenced there but
than that I'd say not so much from book
four chapter eight consumption is the
sole end and purpose of all production
and the interest of the producer ought
to be attended to only so far as it may
be necessary for promoting that of the
consumer well what's a core so now that
go ahead sorry that's just one of the
tidbits that that it's one of my pet
peeves that it gets quoted a lot out of
context as if Smith wanted to say all we
should do is consume as opposed to say
help other people which Smith certainly
didn't believe in context that's again
part of Smith's polemic against
merchants who want the government to
help them in particular who want to help
them promote certain colonial policies
by which for instance the colonies can
only buy from British manufacturers to
that Smith is saying listen the
consumers are what can not you
manufacturers we know the government
shouldn't be out to help you produce
more the point of production is how it
gets to the consumer and in that context
he says government should be
looking to what the consumer needs and
not to what the producer claims that he
or she needs
Daniel mattress Daniel Manhattan you're
on the air yes our current political
discourse in economics you know just
course dumb Donna Smith is always seized
upon by anti-government voices and but
what was the government's that were
around at the time of Adam Smith weren't
they more they were monarchies and what
they were like monopoly monarchies it
were really more akin to I don't want to
offend anybody but like sort of mafia of
one organization you're onto something
there I an antenna said did live in a
time of a lot of tyranny a lot of
despotism and a lot of plunder by
monarchs and others and as a result he
was very concerned about the power of
the state and certainly in the democracy
that he was living in at the time
parliamentary democracy he was worried
about it there as well but you're right
I think it's important to remember that
that context of the time he lived did
that was part of the reason he was
anti-government more importantly though
I think the reason he was
anti-government to the extent he was he
certainly wasn't a an anarchist by the
way he certainly saw role for government
and defense in the court system and
sometimes in other areas but his his
worry was a worry that we should all
have at all times which is the
concentration of power and the
incentives of politicians to do the
right thing that's always a genuine
concern samuel fly shocker what did a
Adam Smith think about the East India
Company oh he hated the East India
Company he thought that was a huge
mistake one of the worse things he
thought that could happen is to have
merchants rule or rulers become
merchants basically because merchants
have an interest that is quite different
from the interests of citizens so he
actually wanted to disbanded and that's
one of his major recommendations in the
wealth of nations and it's actually
quite a shame something of a betrayal of
his legacy that even his friends kept
the East India going a company going
after he died let me just say in
connection with what Russell just said I
agree with all that I in fact would even
add that in the context of the time
Smith is also worried about the
corrupting the democracy because he was
capable of buying out the voters in many
places but I would say that here
libertarians who use Smith to cry
against big government do have a point I
think whether you're on the left or the
right one thing to learn from Smith is
that government can't solve all our
problems and some of the reasons for
that don't have to do with the faults of
monarchy one thing Smith says often and
one thing that I confess I have been
come from a more left-wing background
learned from Smith is that governments
just don't know the right kinds of
things to run a large economies to run
many things in small local situations
you just can't trust a group of
legislators in a centralized office in
the middle of the country to know what's
going on or all throughout the country
better than the people there know
themselves as Smith says ordinary people
can judge better in their own local
situations than any legislator can do
for them and I think that is a very
important kind of message it doesn't
throw out a role for government
government can still do many important
things but one has to ask oneself always
should government do this could this be
better done by the private sector I
think that's something Smith does always
want you to ask Glenn Newton
Massachusetts good evening good evening
I've just finished reading The Wealth of
Nations in a one-volume paperback so
here's a slightly technical question for
either of the gentlemen it's twelve
hundred and fifteen pages in that volume
would the wealth of nations suffer at
all if the entire disquisition on silver
were removed thank you well there are a
lot of passages in Smith that are hard
for modern story that's what I said you
know you should read the first three or
four chapters I met at a minimum but I
didn't mean to suggest that was the only
part that was readable but a lot of
Smith is difficult to read because he's
dealing with economic issues or
institutional details that aren't
relevant to us today or we're not
familiar with so it can be very
difficult going to me what's striking is
that for a book written in 1776 how much
of it is still worth reading but I think
the wise reader who's not a scholar of
Smith as Sam is
I would include me when going back to
the book would dip in where it's most
most judicious and profitable I think
that a good accepted addition could be
put out I haven't yet seen one that I
liked because I think they often leave
out some of the important things about
workers and about public schooling and
about religion in book five the
disquisition of the digression on Silva
I agree with the cholera is the first
thing I think most people want to cut
out on the other hand I gather Russ can
correct me on this that is one of the
things that modern economists think is
most brilliantly done and it actually
makes a very important and impressive
point this guy was tracing prices of
silver over 400 years quite a remarkable
feat even with modern scholarship let
alone with what he had available to him
at the time in order to prove that the
price of silver does not inevitably
decline as his mercantilist opposition
said and I think he does a pretty good
job of it though I can't really judge
the technical details well I just would
add I think it's important for any
reader of any economist not just Adam
Smith to be skeptical of the conclusions
that are drawn a lot of times they're
not always right Smith wasn't right
about everything he wasn't always it
doesn't come from Mount Sinai the wealth
of nations it's not Scripture it's a
profoundly provocative and
intellectually impressive work you
should take every many things in there
with a grain of salt and learn from it
the Edition we have here on the table is
the fifth edition which was a published
in 1789 he made revisions throughout the
five editions but this is in the public
domain right now correct
anybody could publish this book that's
why I said at the library of economics
and liberty econ law org they have an
extraordinarily high quality scholarly
version it's not the you know some
knockoff or other edition but yeah it's
available anybody could take it and edit
it in any way they choose to is that
correct no less true on the last part
yeah Silver Spring Maryland Albert hi hi
thank you for that phone call I just
wanted to ask a question
Phyllis Adam Smith I read it but a very
simple time of simple economy now we are
in a complex financial situation
derivatives or so on globalized economy
how is he relevant to the tools we have
today well you know it's a common
critique of certain older thinkers that
you know their work doesn't apply
anymore it's outdated Smith didn't
anticipate Oh derivatives for example or
credit default swaps or worldwide
investment banking yeah and that's true
he didn't although he had many things in
his day that had some of the flavor of
it but that's why you don't want to read
Smith for explicit understanding of
things but what he did understand many
many things he understood or timeless
he understood the role of human nature
he understood our flaws he understood
our highest aspirations and natures he
understood the role of incentives he
understood the role of opportunity cost
he understood that money isn't
everything he understood that pieces of
paper aren't wealth and that what we can
really acquire is the true measure of
our standard of living with our scarce
labor he's really got a lot to take
let's say at three specific things which
I suspect I'm perhaps unusually Russ and
I may may agree on even on specifics he
has a criticism of the balance of trade
the doctrine of the balance of trade in
which it seems to me he was dead on then
and is dead on now he understands the
importance of education and the
importance of education for everyone and
he understands the wastefulness of war
and he says things about the
wastefulness of war that could have come
right out of the last decades debates
and Samuel fleisch acker this a tweet
came in I would like you to get you to
respond in your view what would Smith
think of the Great Society affirmative
action and welfare it's from blue
capitalist well that would take a very
long time to answer you have your
written written two books on it so the
short answer is those are all issues
that were not remotely on the table at
the moment he died some of them were on
the table within 10 years after he died
there was a huge debate about poor law
what the government should do to aid the
poor which he didn't get to participate
in because he died a little too early my
own view is that a Smith among the
things Smith thought government could do
and should do if it could do it well was
help the poor reaches condition in which
they could participate on the same level
as everybody else in the market and my
view would be that he would support
something like universal health care
today for instance though there are many
Smith Ian's who would disagree with me
you're crazy Shay aspect this meant that
would go out in the other direction he
can take it you don't graze and he can
he can be read in both ways I think
because he wasn't really addressing
those issues health care why do you know
I have no idea what's missus issued on
on you know health care policy minutiae
is I just think he'd be highly skeptical
of a top-down single-payer type solution
but that's a long debate for another
time say I met and I I'm shocked by how
much we agree on so far and both of our
both of our guests are also authors as
well as professor Samuel fly shocker one
of his books is on Adam Smith's Wealth
of Nations and Russ Roberts most recent
book is called the price of everything
you can see it there on your screen who
published it Princeton University Press
and it is about emergent order the idea
of the invisible hand that Hayek
particularly focused on the role of
prices in steering resources it's a
novel by the way it's written to for a
general audience and it's very Smithee
and in its flavor Monroe Louisiana Paul
thanks for holding your own good evening
gentlemen
in my short collegiate career studying
economics at Auburn University the name
of Adam Smith was very rarely spoken
without Thomas Malthus coming up and the
contrast between Smith's optimism and
Malthusian pessimism and the theory the
different schools of positivism and
Norman more normative economics and we
see this today where we see central
planning being look to for global
warming
and maybe we're better off with
individuals deciding what could happen
better with Adam Smith's approach to
people looking after their own interest
in taking care of things that way
professor Roberts well I'm not going to
pretend that Adam Smith would be
interested in a private solution of
global warming I think he'd be worried
as I am about centralization of power in
the hands of bureaucrats I think that's
something to be concerned about any
solution of any social problem I think
the more general point is that Smith
wasn't so aware or have to deal with
what moderate economists call
externalities and that's a case of
pollution global warming would be an
example of that and private solutions to
those although they often make progress
they may struggle and there may be a
role for government in there that Smith
perhaps would have recognized maybe dot
I think he'd have been worried as again
as I am of the role of centralization of
power in steering people's lives not
because so much that centralized power
doesn't fully understand what's on the
ground which was Sam's earlier point but
also the power corrupts and I think
Smith understood that very very clearly
Samuel Fleisch acker Craig Bardot tweets
in did Smith have much to say about
monetary policy oh well that's the one I
would throw back at Russell actually I
think he does have some things to say
but some of this has it is much more
technical and really better handled by a
tech by professional economists if I
could just say something about the
centralization of power going back to
the prior question for a second I think
one reason why Russell and I can agree
in principle and disagree in specifics
about some of these issues is that Smith
basically has two broad broad views
about political economy or politics and
economy on the one hand the government
should do everything that is important
to be done in a society and individuals
can't do for themselves it's very broad
and very vague vague but he does say
that that should happen and he mentions
public schooling especially for the poor
as one thing that might fall into that
category on the other hand he is
definitely worried as
Liz and I am and and as Russell says
about the centralization of power and so
the question is how do you balance those
things how do you have government take
care of problems that individuals can't
handle on their own if that's the case
and global warming might be such a case
health care might be such a case without
on the other hand contributing to the
dangers of great centralization one
difference between Smith and Malthus on
these issues is a difference that has to
do with historical events between the
time Smith wrote and the time Malthus
wrote there was a great famine and
things look darker than they had done in
Smith's lifetime and there was also the
French Revolution and the dangers of
government and governmental reform
looked greater than they had to Smith
and so that's one reason for contrast
but and we're going to get a professor
Roberts very quickly to address Craig
Bardot's tweet yes Mary much to say
about his bailiwick he had a lot to say
about monetary policy the part I want to
mention I think is particularly
interesting for for our current
situation is Scotland between I think it
was 1720 and 1870 1715 1870 for over a
century Scotland had banks issuing their
own money they had private currency in
circulation my colleague at George Mason
Larry white is an authority on that
phenomenon and Smith traces out the
incentives that banks had to be careful
with their currency that they issue
because they don't want to lose the
trust of their customers and that's an
extraordinarily important lesson I think
for us today as we look at the role the
Federal Reserve and I think it's a
reader would profit from reading about
private banking in Scotland something
Smith had a lot of interesting things to
say about and in Cedar Springs Michigan
is Luke Luke please go ahead yeah my
question has to do with all David Hume
and how much influence do you think that
David D is the relationship between Adam
Smith and David Hume and David Humes
philosophy had on am Smith professor fly
shocker that's again a great question
and on the enormous subject much debated
in many ways you can find almost an
anticipation of almost every particular
idea of Smith somewhere in Hulme I think
Smith also tends to disagree with Hume
in small ways at least on almost every
subject so they have a slightly
different view about sympathy they have
a slightly different view about the role
of self-interest in people's lives they
agree largely about the nature of
government the dangers of large
government but also the ways in which
government can can help Society and the
need for government in administering
justice they agree on a lot of economic
issues and disagree in some small ones
it's very hard to tease them apart one
important difference for the purposes of
this discussion is that Smith put all
his thoughts about economics and
government into one large systematic
discussion and that's not something that
Hume did Edie Baltimore good evening yes
I have a question concerning spending
and savings could what would he have to
say about the government spending today
I mean what would happen maybe either
the economist could address this how
much of total GDP is all government
spending and if we cut out most of that
spending just except for the necessaries
of let's say the war any war or defense
we'll call it the defense then what
would employment be like and and without
large amounts of government spending on
the national on the state and the local
level I mean how would capital keep keep
enough employing employment going
because at the present moment business
isn't spending individuals are just
barely spending and the government
doesn't spend where does the spending
come from
I think Smith's would reject as many
economists do but not all the idea that
somehow we have to keep spending up to
keep the economy afloat that's a common
view it's a Keynesian view and it is a
mainstream view among economics but
there's a lot of people who think that's
the wrong approach
to take but Smith was not a
macroeconomist in that sense I think the
part that Smith would have a lot to say
about today would be the example for
example of bailing out General Motors or
AIG or all the money that's flowed into
the investment banks who made lossy
decisions I think he'd recognize that
that's money ill-spent that's money
that's not for the good of the society
at large it's money that's good for the
people who get it and he would I think
be very skeptical about its value and I
think that's the most important lesson
although the size of government is is a
concern in terms of the power of the
state the question is what do they spend
it on as Sam pointed at earlier Smith
was an advocate for the government doing
things that people couldn't do for
themselves well people aren't going to
buy lousy cars for themselves you got to
get the government to do that for him
and I think that's an enormous mistake
and we've got about five minutes left
with our two guests Samuel fly shocker
in Chicago he's a philosophy professor
at the University of Illinois at Chicago
and Russel Roberts an economics
professor at George Mason University
discussion about Adam Smith and the
wealth of nations Kansas City Missouri
melt hi thank you for taking my call
love watching the book TV I watch it all
weekend I've tried to read Adam Smith a
few times I was unable to I don't want
to say comprehend but I wouldn't come a
chem chem major in college but it
appears that some of the underlying
doctrines in this book is that the
consumer it's almost a consumer driven
market which it should be the merchants
should tailor their products to to us so
the consumer can buy them which would
actually help the economy as far as the
government or bailing out the banks and
that and it not being consumer driven
I'm curious on how the underlying
doctrines in Adam Smith's book would
actually see the results of that well
you know Smith talks about the natural
tendency of producers people in business
to gather together to try to exploit
consumers and he saw a competition as a
great great way of preventing that and
he also saw the world of Commerce as a
way of enhancing our virtues that by as
you said earlier by making sure that you
provided a product that people liked you
had to put your shoot yourself in the
shoes of the consumer had to figure out
what the consumer wanted and that force
is extremely important in Smith and I'd
say very missing from some of our public
policy of the last two or three years I
think we've made some disastrous
mistakes and in particular the
consequences of those mistakes whether
you thought they were good or bad
whether there wasn't a better choice
some people would argue I disagree but
if you thought there wasn't a better
choice we certainly now we're going to
have to deal with the incentives that
has for the future and that's something
Smith would have said I had a lot to say
and Andrew sends in a tweet and I want
to start with You professor fly shocker
for both of you to answer very quickly
if you could what would Smith say about
the American economic system if he were
alive now has government intervention
replaced the invisible hand well again
we live in very different circumstances
and this is an issue that it's a very
difficult question to answer and I and I
think resisting answering that question
is very important jumping in and saying
one knows what Smith would say today is
I think quite dangerous I do have a
section at the end of my book if I'm a
tout my book called learning from Smith
today in which I suggest that there are
ways to use him for both right and left
wing approaches to contemporary policy I
don't think that government in the
United States is in fact activist enough
in some areas as I indicated before that
would include health care for me on the
other hand again Russell I'm surprised
at how much we agree I entirely would
agree that we shouldn't have bailed out
the banks and I would agree that
something Smith would have said it's
very important that businesses fail when
they make bad decisions that is
something Smith says and that is a kind
of government intervention that he
opposes coming in to prop up in the
strees because you think that particular
industry is necessary for the economy I
I think Smith would have been worried by
our very large defense establishment as
I said before he worries about
government despair expenditure on war
that there can be much too much of that
I don't think he would have been as
worried about spending on welfare policy
I
you think it's quite clear that he would
have opposed government intervention to
prop up various specific industries all
right before you answer professor
Roberts we want to get Loretta in here
and we're almost out of time go ahead
Loretta in Lansing Michigan
yes businesses are to make profit
consumers are to afford and I do not
believe that it's as complicated
complicating as it sounds I think as a
matter of physics it's the way we are
looking at the situation of the consumer
and the business and professor Roberts
you get the last word well it's a
certain natural health in capitalist
society where it's properly organized
which is businesses that want to thrive
in a profit and loss system have to make
customers happy but as Smith would
remind us and has built and Friedman
often reminded us
it's a profit and loss system so
businesses that don't do well in serving
the consumer or who make bad investments
have to take losses if we don't let
businesses take losses we don't get real
capitalism we get crony capitalism and
that is the road to a very unhealthy
world and that will have to be the last
word we are out of time
Russell Roberts of George Mason
University his one of his many websites
is econ talk if you'd like to go there
and communicate directly with him Samuel
fly shocker who is also the president of
the international Adam Smith Society out
in Chicago Adam Smith society dotnet
gentlemen thank you both very much for
being on book TV in prime time my
pleasure thank you very much Peter want
to let you know that we've got two more
hours of programming coming up tonight
and every night this week we are going
to have a live hour from 8:00 to 9:00
p.m. Eastern Time we've picked a couple
of books that have influenced the
American political system tonight we
looked at the wealth of nations with
Adam Smith on Friday night we're looking
at Silent Spring by Rachel Carson
written in the early 60s and we'll have
her biographer and another gentleman on
to talk about Silent Spring and that'll
be on Friday night now tomorrow night
we're having to current economic authors
on to talk about the current economic
situation a MIDI
Lay's and Dean Baker will be here from
8:00 to 9:00 p.m. to take your calls
emails and tweets and then on a Thursday
night we're going to be talking about
the Afghanistan war with two Afghanistan
authors Seth Jones and Mark Moyer will
be here to take your calls and tweets
but two more hours of book TV in
primetime this congressional recess week
coming up next is Henry Paulson in
conversation with Warren Buffett just
this past week on his new book on the
brink and then after that is an
afterwards that we taped with Peniel
Joseph being interviewed by Washington
Post national editor kevin merida dark
days bright nights but now here's Henry
Paulson and Warren Buffett